un apoyo financiero masivo para la
recuperación del pedido del jefe de
naciones unidas tras una visita a
pakistán donde sobrevoló a algunas de
las zonas asoladas por las peores
inundaciones en décadas después de meses
de fuertes lluvias monzónicas y el
deshielo de algunos de sus glaciares
consecuencia del calentamiento global
he visto muchas catástrofes humanitarias
en el mundo pero nunca había visto una
carnicería climática a esta escala
simplemente no tengo palabras para
describir lo que he visto y what i've
seen
las necesidades son enormes y pide apoyo
financiero masivo y urgente para
pakistán
es una cuestión de justicia paquistaní
está pagando el precio de algo que fue
creado por otros created vaya a ver la
catástrofe climática deja más de 1300
fallecidos medio millón de paquistaníes
han perdido sus hogares y unos 33
millones se han visto afectados las
secuelas perdurarán en el tiempo a la
destrucción de cultivos y casas se suma
el incremento de enfermedades preciosas
por el estancamiento de las aguas y un
ya precario sistema sanitario esta joven
di a luz a su tercer hijo mientras
estaba siendo evacuada en un bote dando
un apoyo
jobim a mi hijo está enfermo e ingresado
en el hospital de campaña su estado era
muy malo tenía fiebre ahora está siendo
tratado por el médico y su estado ha
mejorado soy pobre necesito
inmediatamente un campamento y comida
rito no queriendo mamá ninguna acta de
barinas una nueva guía entre julio y
agosto para que están registro casi 190
por ciento más de lluvias que la media
en 30 años un fenómeno meteorológico
extremo que amenaza con repetirse en
otros lugares del mundo si no se toman
acciones urgentes para ralentizar el
cambio climático